hi my name is antoinette robertson i
play coco connors hi my name is duron
horton and i play lionel higgins brandon
bell and i play troy hi i'm logan
browning and i play samantha white i'm
john patrick amadori and i play gabriel
mitchell hi i'm marquee richardson i
play reggie green
hi i'm ashley blaine featherson jenkins
and i play joelle brooks and we're the
cast of dear white people and we're here
with buzzfeed to play a game of who's
who
whatever i say will be wrong if it's
different than what you say and you're
successful thank you for understanding
that
who's most likely to get caught napping
between takes markings
yeah i would say him too yeah i caught
him sleeping a couple of times
definitely i might have to say
about that i mean
i i can say myself too i have i do take
a lot of naps i just be burning so much
energy rose why i'm like red bull you
know i crashed that
duron
i was gonna run
what do you think i'd do when i go back
to the trailer i i'm studying no but i
was gonna say jerome but duran drinks a
lot of red bulls so i figured that he's
got to keep it going all the time why do
you think he drinks a lot of rebels
because he's always napping
i'm going to go with jerome i'm just
going to he was just asleep at another
press thing we did a couple weeks ago he
was just knocked out for like two hours
honestly i think lionel takes a lot of
energy it's because it's so far from who
he is
as a person
so i think he's really just having to
rest and recharge and i
i really think it's amazing i really i
commend him for it yeah he sleeps a lot
because he's an artist i sleep a lot
because i'm just tired all the time so i
i'm gonna have to say myself on that one
if i can get 15 minutes in in between a
take or a setup i'll do it i'll cut my
lunch in half i'll cut my
30 minute lunch
in half
to get at least 15 minutes of sleep
not for any autistic reasons i'm just
tired who's most likely to give the best
relationship advice
mostly blaine fedeson jenkins
i knew we were gonna say each other
because i mean that's how i feel about
your
your advice and your your aura your your
life your all the things that you share
actually
i was gonna say brandon his brand is
direct he's not a he's not a sugar
coater sometimes you need somebody who's
gonna give it to you straight no chaser
you know what i'm saying and brandon is
that ashley actually
yes
wait that's so crazy
she's like a matriarch she's just very
in a very un-tyranty kind of way
i think ashley is good because she can
put herself in your shoes but also your
partner's shoes like she's able to not
just be siding with you she's kind of
able to level the playing field and and
help you to see the whole picture good
job ashley yeah
thank you my friend no i i would say
marquis i mean i just got married and
marquis
i don't even know if i've told you like
you've given me such great advice just
leading up to getting married and just
as a friend marquis and i've been
friends a long time but marquis gives
really good advice in general he's one
of the most transparent people i know
like mark he doesn't sugarcoat anything
he's not gonna you know falsify anything
he's gonna give you the reel and i think
that those are the best types of friends
to go to when you need relationship
advice specifically yeah i don't follow
all of the other all the [ __ ] i said i
don't follow it
who's most likely to burst out laughing
during an awkward situation you me yeah
[Laughter]
oh it's awkward
antoinette
brandon antoinette you're gonna save me
it's you know what it is it's probably
inappropriate at times
you're laughing
your life is louder than the rounds
usually so that's why
yeah
and i snort so that's probably yeah i
don't know
oh yeah you cackle snort yeah yeah burp
four dollars
ah logan
who are you gonna say
how are you gonna i i might be obnoxious
because i'm thinking myself again
very awkward but no i see logan sure
it's a thousand percent logan
logan is for sure
logan's a gemini first of all she's a
gemini crazy she says
she's gonna be so mad when she sees this
but it's fine she's crazy it's all good
so but i say that to say like logan is
either like
very serious or she's like
laughing at awkward situations like
she's
one she's one or the other
i live off of awkward it's so good if
you're over here and you're laughing to
yourself i know you said something
nobody cared about or listened to and
you're just like
that's kind of like that's that's why we
love her because there she is owning her
world
i don't need anyone else to laugh at my
drugs but me you're damn right who's
most likely to not respond in the cash
group chat
brown brandon
that bro brandon paulville
brandon
brandon
brandon no brandon but see i also like
don't ask the group chat so i was like
who do i not know
it's brandon brandon is like known for
he'll leave a group chat like brandon is
like he's on his own
wavelength checks out there's no one
even comes close
no shame in it
no no no no brandon really just he'd be
like
listen
i get what y'all talking about but i'm
i'm good over here
he just he pops in he pops in when he
needs to but he doesn't like some of us
the rest of us might get like
caught up in like the
just whatever talk
we're in it's not going to engage in the
whatever talk like brandon's like are we
talking about business are we talking
about like what are we talking about is
this important if not then i'm minding
my business we're a part of the group
chat and also i'm like wait wasn't
brandon here a second ago it'll just be
like brandon left the chat you're like
bro what's wrong he's like oh i just it
just was it was a lot going on so i just
i don't know you guys were talking in
the chat i just thought why are we
talking in this chat
there he is back and be like yo who
added me back
no that's not
true the bulk in the group text that's
what it is it's like sometimes it's not
like it could have been one question and
then we all kind of send like 10
different things plus like five gifts on
top of it and so when he gets all the
notifications he's like all right i'm
out of this again yeah
who's most likely to randomly start
singing
you're on oh
this is the right answer durran it is
duran one thousand percent he will like
just be on set like singing some r b or
soulful like he'll sing it to you duran
will come right up to your face and
and then just look and then walk away
just disappear and he'll be like
carrying his like like bluetooth speaker
right here like it's like it's really
the 90s and like just making sure that
everyone else also hears the music that
he wants to sing
very true he's he's very sharing in that
way and i appreciate that about it
sure
i would say me too got a lot of songs in
my head bro
you got a musical background he's a
creator he's an artist he does specimens
and stuff and he just does whatever he
feels in the moment and a lot of that is
singing or rapping or screaming always
music blasting
parking in the parking spot
you know it doesn't matter the time 5 am
7 00 am 7 pm oh duran's here you know
when duran's on set like you always know
who's most liked their character
actually yeah i'm gonna say actually i'm
gonna say actually
actually
wow
good for us
her life aligns with a lot of the stuff
that happens to joelle ashley and joelle
just have that nurturing and like high
achieving like they're like successful
like like the ambition the goal
everything the uh the push that drive
you know so i agree good job all right
far out
abigail abigail maybe it's abigail
she's funny she's really funny sheridan
is just really really funny she's funny
crazy and like witty as her character i
i would say yeah
for sure i said internet okay he said me
i think antoinette is funnier than coco
though thank you baby i appreciate that
you got more comedic timing than she do
yeah yeah
who's the least like their character
duron
one of my favorite things is watching
him turn into lionel it's a magic trick
drawn iran
yeah i don't even know how else to
describe it it's just polar opposites
it's like he's he's a transformer every
time he comes on the set chameleon for
sure you're on
no question i've seen people go like
this when they meet you like
[Music]
him walking in like to like the table
reads with the music and his food and
then he's just and then all of a sudden
just like the pigeon toe and the slumped
shoulders and then the voice and all of
a sudden it's like you're you're
watching something that's just so
incredible as performing
the thing i learned from duron is
character behavior like hands down he's
given me an incredible lesson in
character behavior the third season i
studied james baldwin alive so um shout
out to james baldwin who's most likely
to learn and perfect a tick tock dance
wouldn't be me logan browning
logan hogan
logan
i feel like she's the only one
it's logan for sure for sure you
antoinette now
antoine she dances when i guess it would
also be me like i've definitely like
just i've actually done it before but
i'm gonna say we're you're you're taking
a cheat here because you literally dance
all the time when it was like i'm a
savage i was like i'm a savage
i feel like she's the cast member that's
like the most like techno savvy that
she's online
who's going on making reels and videos
and the rest of us are like
just tell us what to do and we're going
to show up and we'll be there girl cause
we don't know what's going on who's most
likely to be the life of the party
marquee marquis yeah
marquee
easy
i like to party
i like to have fun but marquis is also
the life like marquis loves to dance and
like have a good time like he's like
good vibes only he's never trying to
like have a down he's like if you're
down even when things are like a party
vibe he'll he'll still go over to you
and be like are you okay like
are you you good he's the guy at the
party just making sure everything's
the flow is still okay
yeah if you're like going this way it
comes at you this way you wind up going
this way with him and then yeah that i
guess that's the epitome of like life
for the party oh all right we're going
over here now i'm with you that's
happened to me multiple times hey dude
i'm gonna oh okay all right
me
brandon be making funny faces in the
party too so i'll be cracking up it's
like
look season two wrap party
[Laughter]
last one who's most likely to cry on the
last day of filming into that
i mean internet be crying she definitely
she does i do
everyone really we're just all big old
babies you really are
both of us
y'all saw the final scene right
marquee and i be a mess i don't know
what it is
it was your energy that was coming
through me and i was like what's
happening
please please make sure to check out the
final season
the musical season of dear white people
[Music]
you